These groups defined rock and roll.
Welcome to WatchMojo.com, and today we're counting down our picks...
...for the top ten greatest rock bands of all time.
Number ten: Radiohead.
After gaining popularity with the rise of alternative rock,...
...Radiohead proved they weren't a one-note band...
...with OK Computer's more complex sound and abstract theme.
Number nine: The Beach Boys.
They initially rose to fame with their smooth vocal harmonies...
...and carefree, California-inspired surf rock tunes.
Soon, the talent and chart success of America's band...
...gave rise to their being touted as worthy rivals to the Beatles.
Number eight: U2.
It's hard to deny Bono's passionate onstage performances and vocal chops...
...aren't a big reason why U2 is one of the world's biggest bands.
But there's also The Edge's distinctive guitar and the band's live chemistry...
...that have contributed to their international popularity.
Number seven: Metallica.
After their early fast-paced and aggressive sound and complex compositions...
...positioned them as one of thrash metal's Big Four,...
...Metallica turned their underground following into mainstream popularity with "The Black Album".
Number six: The Who.
These Brits cemented their reputation as a destructive but entertaining live act,...
...thanks to Pete Townshend's loud and fast guitars,...
...Keith Moon's wild and sensational drumming, and Roger Daltrey's adaptable vocals.
After setting the blueprint for the rock opera with "Tommy",...
...they took over the airwaves...
...and found a spot within the Billboard Top Ten with every subsequent album,...
...thanks to their rebellious yet ambitious rock and roll.